(audience cheering)
- Welcome back, y'all.
My next guest is one of
the bestselling authors
on the planet.
Since her debut novel in 2012,
she has sold over 40 million books
and redefined the fantasy genre.
Her latest is "House of Flame and Shadow,"
the third book in her
"Crescent City" series.
This is amazing, actually,
just check this out.
How many people actually showed up
to her midnight release party last week.
It's like Taylor Swift went somewhere.
Isn't it crazy?
Is that normal by the way?
Like last night?
I mean, even "Vulture" wrote
something about you like,
you did this release and
like it just blew up.
It literally was like Taylor
Swift was releasing an album,
like all these people showed up.
Is that normal?
- Well-
- I guess you feel like
a tool answering that.
- I don't know.
- Is it, yeah,
I was like, "Wait,
that's a weird question."
But, I mean, that's amazing, the impact.
- You know what, you know what,
you know, this was
actually my first event,
like in person event since COVID.
- Oh my goodness.
- Yeah.
So this was kinda like my first time
like back in the flesh.
- Well, by the way, you're in demand.
Look at that.
Like, well that's, you're
doing, you're doing it right.
- Oh my god, it was amazing.
It was just amazing being out there
and like seeing the
readers face to face again
after so many years and.
- And you've created this
world, like whichever series,
you know, they're addicted to or into,
like you've created this whole world
that y'all are all a part of.
That's really cool.
- Yeah, no, it's just, it's, I mean,
it still feels like a dream come true.
Like I wanted to be a writer
since I was 16 years old.
- That's amazing.
- Yeah.